だいぶましにはなりましたがまだ風邪気味です
はじめしゃちょーです
はい皆さん今年ももうちょびっとですね
もう一週間もないですよ
皆さん今年いかがでしたか？
僕今年ーーーーーーーーーーあんまり楽しくなかった
楽しかったですよ
楽しかったですけど
全体的な生活の質
を考えるとあんまり高くなかった
生活の質あんま高くなかった
今年は体調のこと考えて
食べ過ぎててダメだなと思ってたんで
今年はとりあえず禁止しようと思ってなんとかお菓子、ジュース禁止してなんとかここまで来たんですけど
やっぱね食べたい物が食べれないっていうのは非常に辛くて
精神的に厳しい1年でした、よく頑張ったはじめん
というわけで今日はですね
あの僕ジュース禁止してたとき何を飲んでたかというと
炭酸水を基本的に毎日飲んでました
基本的に炭酸ジュースが好きなんすよ
コーラとか
あっ、コーラもうすぐ飲めんじゃん
オランジーナも
ふおおおお！！！
もう1週間もしないうちに飲めるんだよ
とりあえず僕炭酸系のジュースが大好きで
それを禁止してる時点で今年はほぼ終わったようなもんですよ
今年はもう”終わり”の年でした
それくらい辛かったんですけども
その辛い中でも少しでも気を紛らわせるために
僕は炭酸水という無味、シュワシュワする水を飲んでたわけですよ
今日のために炭酸水をはたして今年1年で何本飲んだかというのを調べようと思ったので
僕が飲んだ炭酸水のゴミを基本的に全部取ってあります
本当は多分あそこにあるやつよりもっと多いんですよ
一回母ちゃんにゴミと間違えられて20,30本捨てられたので
僕が今年飲んだ炭酸水の数が決まると思います
じゃあ数えていきましょう
もう呼吸をするより飲んでたから多分やばいと思うんすよね
炭酸水の量は
( ^)o(^ )
これ持ってきた中でもまだ半分もいってませんからね
これ多分机の上を余裕で超えますな
全然足りない気がしてきた
あ～もう多分机の上じゃ無理だな
下に敷いてきます
はい！僕は1年でこれだけの炭酸水を飲みましたーー
何本？
+5本だから134
ひゃくさｎ..140＋100は
あれ？
ここにあるの全部と＋1日1本飲むから＋5くらいしとくと
240本でございました
（ファッ！？）
*拍手*
思ったより少なくね？
いやでも母ちゃんに結構捨てられてるから
それを含めると多分わかんない
300くらいはいってると思います
あれ？1日1本飲んでねーぞ
えーたまにサボってたのか
たまにサボってたんだ
たまにサボってた、ごめんなさい
1日1本は嘘だったんですけども
この量は確実に飲んでます
240本でしょ？
1本500mlだから
120リットルですね
120リットルは僕は炭酸水を飲んでいることになります
少なくともね。
でもなんかすごい炭酸水は体にいいらしいので
僕はやってよかったと思います
ほんとコイツと歩んだ1年だった
今年は炭酸水があったからこそ僕は健康でいられたのかと思います
1年間炭酸水生活をしてみて思ったことは
（ざわ・・・ざわ・・・）
コーラが飲みてー
（お疲れ様でした）